[موسيقى]
راعي بقر او لاعب بيسبول او محقق او ضابط
امريكي يدافع عن الهنود الحمر مثل وغنى
كتب الاغنيات انتج الافلام واكثر من ذلك
مواهب متعدده جعلت من كيفن كوستنر نجما
كبيرا في هوليود فما قصته ولد كيفن كوستنر
في عام
1955 بولايه كاليفورنيا لاب يعمل في خدمات
الكهرباء ويتنقل كثيرا بين المدن فلم يكد
يكون صداقات حتى يترك المدرسه وينتقل الى
مكان اخر ومدرسه جديده وهو ما جعله يبحث
عن ضلته في الفنون وهو في سن مبكره وتمتع
بمهارات متعدده فكتب الاشعار ومارس كره
القدم
وبنى وهو في سن 18 زورقه الخاص وجد دفع في
الانهار
اثناء دراسته الجامعيه للتخصص اداره
الاعمال اخذ كيفن دروسا في التمثيل ثم حصل
على وظيفه في مجال التسويق ثم قادته
الصدفه لاهم منعطف في حياته عندما قابل
ريتشارد بيرتن على متن رحله جويه من
المكسيك ونصحه باقتحام هذا العالم فترك
مهنته وانتقل الى هوليود في هوليود عمل
كيفن بوظائف غريبه فقد شاحنه وعمل في قارب
صيد في اعماق البحار وقام بجولات بالحافله
الى منازل النجوم وانتظر ست سنوات قبل ان
يحصل على دور حقيقي كممثل في عام 1983
حيث ظهر في فيلم ثم
ظهر بعد عامين في دوري راعي بقر في فيلم
سيلفرادو ليبدا مسيرته المهنيه كممثل صاعد
في الافلام ذات الطابع الغربي
بعدها قدم كافن شخصيه اليوتنس في فيلم ذا
انت تشابلز عام
1987 وهو الدور الذي نال استحسانا كبيرا
وحصل عنه على اعلى اجر في حياته مليون
دولار ما جعله يذهب لافق ابعد مع عمل جديد
هو فيلم دانسيز كمخرج وممثل ومنتج فحاز
الفيلم على سبع جوائز اوسكار وحصل كافن
عنه على جائزتي الاوسكار كافضل مخرج وافضل
ممثل كما حصل عنه على جائزه جولدن كلوب
لافضل مخرج في اواخر الثمانينيات خلقت
ادواره في الافلام الناجحه فيلد اوف جيمز
علاقه دائمه بينه وبين رياضه البيسبول
بعد بضع سنوات غرق كوستنر مره اخرى في
الانتاج الشاق لملحمه خيال علمي باهظه
الثمن
وكان بمثابه قنبله شباك التذاكر في عام
1997 كما قدم لاحقا العديد من الاعمال
الناجحه مثل
والمسلسل الدرامي يلوستون الذي اهله للفوز
بجائزه جولدن جلوب لهذا العام لم يكتفي
كيفن بكونه ممثلا ومخرجا ومنتجا بل اراد
ايضا ان يعلن عن موهبته المتميزه في
الغناء فخطا نحو هذا المجال مع فرقته
مودرن ويست واطلق البومه الاول
عام 2008 وقام بالعديد من الجولات الفنيه
ليقدم اغنياته التي لاقت استحسانا لدى
الجماهير كما كتب الاغنيات وعازف الجيتار
ايضا خاض تجربه ادبيه مع جيمبرغ لكتابه
روايه ذا اكسبلورز التي تتناول قصه مجموعه
من المغامرين تشارك في تحد عالمي للعثور
على مدينه اسطوريه في زمن الحرب العالميه
الاولى قدم كوستنر لاحقا ما يزيد على 60
عملا حصد عنها الكثير من الجوائز كالبافته
وايمي ونقابه الممثلين وغيرها بالاضافه
للاوسكار كما احرز ثروه تقدر بربع مليار
دولار وبات يمتلك اسطولا من السيارات
الحديثه بعد ان قاد حافلات النقل في اروقه
هوليود